forget what you know about adrian
grenier
indeed he was that playboy celebrity
heartthrob much like vincent chase the
character he played on entourage but
these days his life looks nothing like
vinnie's
he lives on a farm and is working to be
fully self-sufficient
he's a partner in do contra ventures a
do-good investment fund and he hosts a
youtube channel called earth speed where
he shares lessons for others who want to
try farming and homesteading
and most of all
he was willing to face his demons and
completely turn his life around
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
you know i've known each other a long
time we're trying to figure it out it's
been like 15 years yeah you told me a
story
you broke up with your girlfriend
a while it's not that long ago
and i talked to you in the moment of
being broken up
where are you going with this simon and
i'll be honest with you i forgot
everything you said but in the moment
was that that impact no no no no no but
in the moment i remember thinking this
is absolutely profound and i really
should internalize some of this yeah so
clearly i didn't which is why we're
having this conversation again
but you went on a journey of
self-discovery of what it means to be
a partner
what it means to be
i mean a lot of things
can you just take me on that journey
because i want to learn it
and this was recently i mean a few years
ago right it was during the pandemic
yeah
essentially i had a rock bottom moment
what i call a
cosmic [ __ ] slap
in which my girlfriend
dumped me
and i was so incredulous i was like
wait what you're breaking up with me
do you know who i am like do you see all
the things i have i'm
the man and i just didn't understand it
and i was like hey what are you doing
like we're we're supposed to get married
and we're supposed to have kids and
we're supposed to have a life together
and we'd been together for four years
and i was like
i didn't understand i could not conceive
of it and she casually just
slid
a list of reasons
to me
across the proverbial table
and she goes
you're a terrible person and i have to
get as far away from you as possible in
fact don't call me don't text
block block block block block
and
i you know i thought i thought that she
was just out of her mind
because i had
accomplished so much i had a lot of
material
things to offer
and look at me
i'm cool i'm living in the coolest spots
real estate markets are popping off
around me
and it just took me a while to really
let it sink in and then i opened up her
list and i
and i started to like go through each
one
and i realized oh my god she is actually
an angel
who
was like the first person in my entire
life that was able to get me to look at
myself
in a very real deep way
and
i began to
what was on the list
yeah
i mean you can't you know i mean really
it was
a lot around
my indulgence my selfishness my
narcissism i mean she was throwing
around words like sociopath and stuff
like that i thought that was a little
bit extreme
but um you know the essence of what she
was saying is
that i was
too self-involved
i had too much vanity
i was out for pleasure and indulgence
and
i wasn't really looking out for the
people around me and
they weren't looking out for me
they had toxic relationships
and an unhealthy relationship to
escapism what made you
so open to have that kind of
cosmic [ __ ] slap no i wasn't i wasn't
are you rejecting no no i was going
about my life i thought i had it all
figured out but if somebody tells you
that kind of stuff the immediate
reaction is defensive you're crazy you
don't know what you're talking about 100
yeah but that wasn't your reaction it
was at first oh it wasn't yeah it was at
first no but i told her on her way out
the door and i have to admit there was a
part of me this nine
sense of dread that i had for years
where i was just waiting for the other
shoe to drop
because i was like things are too
perfect and it was suspicious nothing
ever goes wrong with me like something's
going to happen at death or something
bad
if you look around at all the suffering
and i'm getting away with everything
and my career is doing really well and
i'm
i'm just killing it at life and i'm like
just dressed you could sense the
imbalance i sensed that something was
off
and then when she left me i said to her
i said look i love you and
because i love you i'm gonna take a look
at all of these things
but i'm gonna do it on my own time
so that i can
honestly say that i took a look at it
i'm not just gonna do it to get you back
i'm not going to try and pretend like
i'm going to make all these changes
just because i don't want to lose you
i was like okay goodbye ciao and i'd
broken up with lots of people before and
you know just go find another right and
so it was just
i had never been
so moved to actually do anything i just
would go on to the next indulgence or
the next escape yeah she really jarred
me i used the analogy that you know i
was almost as if you know how when you
when you're waking up from a dream and
you're like like you've been in rem
sleep and you're groggy and you can kind
of know that you've been sleeping you're
kind of becoming conscious of the fact
that you're asleep
it's that moment i was like oh i've been
asleep at the wheel for 20 years driving
at high speeds and leaving a wake of
destruction and i don't even know what i
was up to for the past 20 years of my
life
i was essentially unconscious
so what do you do i mean it's one thing
to get a little bit of feedback but to
be forced to reevaluate
your entire absolutely everything self
personality the way you show up the way
you were a friend the way you're a
boyfriend yeah i'm so curious sort of
what's the first step well and to look
at yourself and admit
and to face the shame
and the embarrassment
so what'd you do what's the first thing
you did i had to purge a lot of stuff
you got physically got rid of stuff well
yeah um the lifestyle stuff i
went sober i went celibate just cut
everything out
said no i had to learn to say no
so that i could actually find some peace
and safe space
quiet space for me to actually take so
we're talking about simple stuff i want
to go out for dinner tonight want to go
to a party tonight no
do you want this acting job no yeah and
this was a long process because
i had been so used to saying yes to
every single impulse and opportunity to
get a dopamine hit you know i was
conditioned to just do do anything just
because it was offered to me or it was
available
and so yeah i did a fuckload of
meditation
um
i did some plant medicine isn't that the
name of your app [ __ ] load of meditation
exactly
yeah look
i did all the things i read all the
books i listened to the podcasts i
started to take interest in
what i need to do to actually become a
person that jordan wouldn't have left
you didn't want to become the person
that she would take back you wanted to
become the person that she would never
have left yes
yeah
yeah and and i and i started to like
peel back the layers and look at where
did i go wrong or where when did i fall
asleep yeah and i just went back and
back and then i went into my 30s and
then in my 20s and then further back
into my teens
and then even further back to my
childhood and that's i mean that's what
this inner journey this personal
development work is is about really
going back as far as you can to when you
first started making those decisions to
escape and run and hide and numb
you know the pain or the the suffering
or the traumas that you endured as a as
a kid it was just a two-year journey uh
what do they call it a dark night of the
soul you're so open about this i thought
that's what this was for no
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is that not this podcast
no no but i mean
it's a compliment because you're
portraying yourself as not a nice person
of the past now you're lovely
you know it's one thing to do it in
private with a friend the reason i
wanted you to do this is because i think
that your journey has value to others i
think there's a reason to share pain and
discomfort it's an act of service i
agree
and so how did the conversation go how
did you
reconnect with jordan i was i guess at
the
at the furthest extent of my personal
transformation if you will
and through my process i realized that i
needed to be in the earth
i need to be grounded i was essentially
for
the past 20 years
flying high peter pan syndrome not
touching the ground so i needed to be in
the earth so i started working with the
soil and i built a community garden and
that's the work i was doing that was my
focus and i purged everything else i'd
quit acting i'd quit all my real estate
ventures and my business
pursuits and i was just working with the
earth and i realized what i want what i
really truly want what my soul wants is
family
to be close to nature
and
to
give my life force for
my children
that i want to have
i'm done living for myself and my own
boyish indulgences
so i wanted to grow up be on my own
survive take care of myself
and my family
and have the capacity then to give my
life force to my neighbors and my in my
community and the world at large not in
the rhetorical way that i do when i
have a a non-profit that i you know
raise money for so that other people can
do the work and raise money so that they
can go save the world but so that i can
actually show up in a reliable way and
have the skills to be able to offer
somebody
my service
and so
when i thought that i was
kind of getting it and i was ready
i was looking for a piece of land that i
wanted to go move to and i wanted to
learn how to build a house in my mind it
was like symbolic i should be able to
survive
you know outside of the
protection of
civilized society where everything's
handed to you and everything's mediated
for your consumption you know just buy
it or you know go work for the man and
then consume more stuff i wanted to go
be more in touch with my own ability to
make things you took all the metaphors
literally
well and i think there's a reason yeah i
think you learn certain things when you
you hone those survival skills so you've
got a piece of land so no i was going to
get a piece of land okay but i was going
so far down the archetype prepper role
where i was like okay this beard can get
longer i can be farther away in nature
next thing you know i'm living off the
land and eating out of 10 cans
you know and afraid of the world and i
was like that's that's not what i want
so i i needed to pull back on the reins
and i realized
i want relationship i don't want to be
isolated i want to actually be in the
world
but i do want to be in nature so
i decided i was going to buy land but i
couldn't do it
i couldn't do it until
i found my partner
because it wasn't land for you it was
land for us whoever us was going to be
right and if i went and i did it and
then i invited somebody like a partner
into the land then it would be my thing
and they would be part of my thing as
opposed to it being our thing right so i
first had to solve the relational
dynamic thing so i started dating i
tried to date
and that didn't go so well
because i knew that until i resolved
all the things
with my ex i was just gonna keep playing
out those patterns so i had to find
closure with my ex so that's when i
long story short that's when i reached
out to her
and again blocked on everything she
contests this she thinks that no you
weren't blocked but
i thought i was
and so i emailed her
i sat down i had all the time in the
world to construct the perfect email and
i said
listen i've made a lot of changes
and i'm sure you've heard it all before
but
uh i have
no job i'm not working
i have no distractions i'm not dating
anybody i'm not having sex with anybody
i'm celibate i'm sober and
all i have is time and i will spare no
expense to
find closure and healing with you no
agenda i'm not trying to get back with
you i just want to make make things
right and then at that point we'll see
if we want to be friends we can be
friends if we want to get back together
if we want to part ways at least
then
i can go about my life and start dating
new people with a clean mind
and and so can you
she was you know suspicious at first but
she was open
she's like i knew you were going to
reach out i felt it and she's like
i drew this picture of what i wanted to
manifest and she sent me a picture and
it was a picture of like land and a
house
and a river and
trees and the whole thing i was like
that's it like it were perfect right
let's get together and she's like not so
fast
i need to
you're saying the right words but i want
to feel it and i can't feel it through
email right we have to see each other i
said great i'll show where are you i'll
come meet you and she's like i moved to
portugal
[Laughter]
and
i was like all right cool i'll i'll come
to portugal she goes good luck there's a
ban on travel to to europe but from
americans because it's kovid
i was like okay challenge accepted
i got to portugal
and she made me jump through hoops and
it took months for us to really truly
find closure but the truth is we were
soul mates i mean we were meant to be
together yeah this is all this is part
of the journey part of the journey so
we've we were together for four years we
were part for two and now we're back
together almost for two years
we got land we named our ranch consugue
ranch i know consuge yeah japanese
already repairing things with gold
that's right broken things with gold and
so we are living
the essence of kinsugi it's more
beautiful after it's broken
it's beautiful
you are a different person now i mean
it's like it's kind of obvious to anyone
who's known you
there is a calm about you
you're more philosophical as well
i don't believe in good bad right wrong
i believe that everything is balanced
and i believe that everything that you
get in life
or any advantage you have comes at a
cost you know there's a cost for money
you make there's a cost for fame there's
a cost for success you know
there's a cost for eating chocolate cake
and at the same time anything bad that
happens quote-unquote bad comes with
opportunity comes with lessons
and covert was that i think for all of
us if you chose to see it yes there was
pain and yes there was depression every
one of us went through something and
it's a strange thing to say but i became
an adult during covet yeah
you know i'm considered middle aged
though i never felt it
yeah and it sounds even weird to even
say it and prior to covid i was very
uncomfortable when people called me a
man
yeah you know i prefer to call myself a
boy
you know because i felt like a boy i
believe last time we hung out before
kova we were having ice cream cones like
we went guys yeah we went we did we went
that's exactly what we did we went for
ice cream it's i think it's actually
worse than that and i think we actually
shared an ice cream in a cup in a big
cup like we got a large i think
but not peter pan in the sense like the
way you described your peter pan like i
wasn't as indulgent as you
i just liked the idea that i didn't have
to grow up and be responsible yeah i
think that's what my my boyishness was
sure you know one of the weirdest ways
it looked which is i became
uncomfortable looking in my in the
mirror and like seeing gray hair i mean
prior to covet if i had a gray hair i
was like oh my god i have a gray hair
i'm like of course i'm going to get a
gray i'm like that age
but it it shattered my image of myself
as the boy yeah right and now i just
don't care like now i'm like i'm okay
being my age which is kind of a funny
thing when you become the adult then you
have to take responsibility and you
don't have anyone to blame yeah like
you're the one who's going to
do the right thing in every moment yeah
you know you can't skirt responsibility
the thing the thing that's important
here and this is what we're skirting
around is it's all fine and good for us
to say how you know we became adults yes
we do become daughters um so what like
what's the lesson here is this something
that everybody goes through like is this
is this a warning hopefully every gen z
you lived a life that for the most part
has become a standard of what success
looks like
there's an entire generation coming up
who
wants what you had yeah
you know shouldn't our generations be
looking at it going no no no
we're going to live a life of service
we're going to work in ourselves
when i go through depression or hardship
i'm going to deal with it with the
people around me who i owe as opposed to
turning on my camera and simply crying
basically by myself yeah then editing it
slightly and putting it on youtube right
well i would just you know
throw it back to you in terms of what
you said before it's we're always in
balance right so i don't i don't know if
we're worse i think we're definitely in
a collective awakening so i see from
the people that i choose to surround
myself with now yeah a lot of people who
are making different choices yeah
and and yeah it might just be a natural
rite of passage you know it's like our
parents are always like these crazy kids
right you know and now here we are grow
growing up and becoming
those mature adults hopefully
and the youth seem strange or out of
touch or i mean that's look i'm not of
course every youth seems strange because
they grew up differently than us of
course to every generation but my
lamentation like i lament the loss of
service
you know
and serve always by definition comes at
some sort of
suffering
i mean you said it i can put my face or
give some money to charity ha ha i've
served no no there has to be suffering
to serve and in your case you served
jordan you served your relationship you
served the land and none of that stuff
was easy or or is easy like the work is
never ever ever done
you know when you toil the land you told
the land for the rest of your life yes
you know it's not like you planted once
your hands are dirty you wash them
you're good and that's the same i think
that's the metaphor which is you know i
did the work on myself it's no i'm doing
the work on myself right nobody did the
work i'd be very suspicious on anybody
said i did the work
okay so you're living on the land you
built this land you're not
self-sufficient yet
no i'm learning i took a class i learned
permaculture i got my permaculture
certificate but i also just watch a
shitload of youtube videos i mean
there's so much learning so many people
offering
their understanding or their help
so anytime i have a question about
anything i just go to youtube so i
realize this is a really powerful
networking tool outsourcing wisdom and
skills
so we started earth speed as a means to
share our experience on the land and
hopefully inspire people to
take it on themselves and try
homesteading and try to learn um
permaculture so what exactly is earth
speed is it it's a youtube channel oh
it's a youtube youtube channel yeah it's
social media channel got it right and
then ultimately down the road would be
how-to videos and uh speaking to thought
leaders and entrepreneurs about
different ways to live in community and
live closer to nature and learn how to
be self-reliant
can you tell me an early specific happy
childhood memory
i think this is
this shows
the mischievous troublemaker side of me
we were kids and my grandmother used to
smoke and so we snuck
some of her cigarettes and
her lighter
and we went in the back of the shed
and we were trying to smoke and it was
gross so we got bored quickly
but then we realized we had this lighter
and there were some leaves around
and we had matchboxes so
we went we grabbed some alcohol rubbing
alcohol and we doused the
matchbox cars with alcohol and then we
lit them on fire and then we would push
them across
the little piece of concrete
and they would jump over the concrete
and then into the pile of leaves and
then the leaves would catch fire and
that was so much fun until
until the fire got out of control and we
couldn't put it out
but then it got to be even more fun
because then we ran and we got the hose
and we were pretending like we were
firemen
and trying to put out the fire
and we ultimately ended up
well actually i don't know if we we
succeeded but um someone came running
out and like helped us put it out and we
got in trouble
but
that was that's that's what came to mind
i have this mischievous grin on my face
as you're telling the story
because you're basically recapping
the story of jordan
which is you live this indulgent life
which is oh my god
matches
fire this is so fun you're jumping
things in ignited matchbox cars into
pisa leads it gets even more ridiculous
this is the good life right it gets out
of hand and you realize okay i know this
is out of hand i'm living a life of this
crazy indulgence but my god it's fun
yeah
and then at some point you realize
[ __ ] i have to face this and put the
fire out and then that starts a new
journey it seems like a reaction it
seems like an ability to take hold of
the fire but you realize you're actually
starting on a completely new journey and
earth speed is part of that
new journey i mean that's you know
basically what you want to do is teach
people show people that the new journey
they're putting out the fire they're
living a simpler life
it's just a better journey it's a new
journey a new part of life so i love
that
everything you're doing now is it
actually fits that
brilliantly
that's amazing hey
thanks so much for swinging by it's it's
really good to see i haven't seen you in
person in a long time and it's really
nice to see you i really appreciate it
oh man this is fun
[Music]
if you'd like to learn more about the
work adrian is doing
check out earthspeed on youtube
and a special thanks to aloe yoga who
let us use their studios to record this
episode if you enjoyed this podcast and
would like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then
take care of yourself
take care of each other
you